okay so this video we're going to
discuss viral replication following the
lysogenic cycle so let's go ahead and
get started okay so when we get into the
steps of the lysogenic cycle we can
really break it down into five stages
and we're going to call the first one
the attachment stage and like the name
implies the virus will land on the cell
membrane of the host so here comes the
virus notice how there are these little
objects marked receptors on the cell
membrane the virus itself has these
little bumps and little balls of protein
on the outer surface so the virus will
act will actually attach to these
receptors you know the lock and key
analogy works really well here the virus
has these little bumps of proteins on
them and if they are able to match the
receptor of the cell then the attachment
is successful so when we move on into
the second stage of the lysogenic cycle
that's called entry like the name
implies the nucleic acid the genetic
material the DNA or the RNA of the virus
is going to enter the host cell this
happens usually in a one of two ways
one is that the nucleic acid is
literally injected into the host cell
this animation however is going to
follow the other way and that is and
that is that the virus the entire virus
is swallowed into the cell notice how an
indentation has begun more and more and
more of the viruses being taken into the
host and eventually the entire virus has
been taken into the host cell so what
happens next our enzymes inside the
virus will cause the capsid to break
down this releases the nucleic acid into
the cytoplasm of the host what actually
happens next is that viral DNA will
actually be spliced into
and combined with the DNA of the host
cell so watch this enzymes will actually
break open the host cell's genome and
there and that allows the viral DNA to
bond with in fuse with the host cell DNA
this combination of part cell DNA in
black and part virus DNA in purple is
what is called a pro virus this occurs
during the entry stage of the lysogenic
cycle so before we go any further I want
to zoom out for a wider view of our cell
here what comes next is a latent time
period the pro virus will enter a stage
of latency and the word latent simply
means dormant the viral DNA will lie
dormant inside of the host cell and the
host cell carries on its activities as
if nothing's wrong
and so the infected cell simply carries
on and eventually divides by mitosis the
difference being every time the the host
cell divides it makes a copy of the
provirus during the cell cycle of
mitosis the DNA is duplicated and then
the cell begins to divide in the -
notice how there are now two infected
cells when originally there was only one
so each newly created cell contains a
copy of the pro virus now this process
happens over and over and over and over
and might happen over and over and over
for years just depending upon the virus
so as the process happens over and over
and over again the cell on the Left
divides into two more infected cells the
cell on the right goes through mitosis
and divides into two more infected cells
for a total of four now so the one
infected cell became - two became four
the four would continue on the 8 the 8
would continue onto 16
sixteen would continue on 232 and so on
and so on and so on
well now let's kind of get back to the
lysogenic cycle here let's focus on one
single cell just for simplicity and
let's zoom on into that one cell for a
closer look
so Stage three is called replication
eventually the latent period in the
stage of the lysogenic cycle will end
the viral DNA will become active and
this kind of signifies step three of
called replication the DNA of the virus
will perform DNA replication to make
more DNA and that's the definition er of
DNA replication is the process of
creating DNA from a DNA template
remember a template is kind of just
another word for a mold so in my
animation there's one molecule of DNA
created there's a second created there's
a third so multiple molecules of DNA are
replicated the DNA that was just created
then undergoes transcription in order to
make RNA if you forgotten what
transcription is it's the process of
creating RNA from a DNA template now the
difference being the viral DNA in purple
is going to be used to make the viral
RNA and input in purple as well so
there's one piece of viral RNA here's
another molecule of viral RNA created
and here's another molecule of viral RNA
created through the process called
transcription so now what happens next
is the cell the host cell has ribosomes
that will perform translation on behalf
of the virus viruses don't have
ribosomes themselves so they kind of
hijack ribosomes that belong to the host
so the definition of translation if you
forgot is the process where a ribosome
will create a protein so there's a
ribosome there's a
paison there is a ribosome and through
the process of translation a bunch of
amino acids are gathered and collected
at the ribosome to make a protein and
notice in this case the protein looks an
awful lot like the capsid of a new virus
that's because the capsid is made from a
proto is made of protein so the same
thing happens on the other piece of RNA
the process of translation occurs where
the ribosome will actually gather a
bunch of amino acids and build them
together into two a collection of
protein and there we see another capsid
of another virus created and one more
time
here we have a ribosome collecting a
bunch of amino acids and as the amino
acids are built together into a
collection of protein and here we have a
third capsid created so the process keep
in mind we're now dealing with more than
one infected cell because of that latent
period when the cell went through
mitosis and divided the process also
takes place inside of the other infected
cells and so we come to stage four
called assembly the viruses the parts of
the viruses that have been created will
self assemble here we see DNA and a
capsid coming together to make a new
virus here we see DNA in a capsid coming
together to make a new virus and finally
the third virus is created and that
leads us to step five known as release
like the name implies the viruses are
going to be released from the host cell
and this happens in many cases because
the virus will release enzymes that will
pop little holes and poke little holes
in the cell membrane of the host this
will actually cause the cell to lyse or
to burst once that happens those viruses
are
least to repeat the process he keep in
mind the process also takes place inside
of the other infected body cells so here
are those four infected cells now now
I'm not implying that it's a ticking
time bomb and all your cells are and
explode at one time I'm not implying
that at all what I am trying to show you
is that multiple cells will have their
cell membranes punctured and multiple
cells will burst and and this will
release multiple a large massive amount
of new viruses
this is the lysogenic cycle so as we
finish up you know pause the video if
you want to try this practice quiz and
if you're in my biology class bring me
your answers before school or after
school I'd be happy to check your
answers for accuracy good luck everyone